s'il y en a bien un seul qui n'était pas
content ce weekend c'était bien Gargamel
AB Buc c'était le rendez-vous annuel des
B desfil plus de 8000 d'entre eux sont
venus chasser les dédicaces chaque année
on vient pour faire dédicacer quelques
band dessiné de mon fils je suis très
contente parce que j'aime bien cette
série des profs je suis venu avec ma
fille et mon fils qui tourne partout
parce que parce que c'est c'est juste
génial de tous ces auteurs qui sont en
train de dessiner de découvrir comment
il dessine et cetera et puis après il y
a le plaisir de repartir avec son livre
et et sa dédicace je l'ai rencontré
Monsieur vin je suis venu que pour lui
1993 premier festival un rendez-vous
auquel participait déjà westerlin
l'auteur de docteur poche Jeanette
pointue ou encore Tucker je suis venu
déjà dans les premiers puis les années
passé on est pas toujours libre puis il
faut que ça qu' un nouvel album au moins
mais c'est un super festival ça ne
m'étonne pas qu'il ait évolué dans un
sens semblable en 30 éditions le
festival a fédéré de nombreux auteurs
plus d'une quarantaine ont accepté de
participer cette année des habitués
comme des petits nouveaux je suis venu à
Buc régulièrement parce que j'habitais à
côté j'habitais à iniign donc c'était
vraiment très proche j'aimais beaucoup
cette ambiance le château le parc et
cetera j'aime bien les l'équipe qui s'en
occupe parce qu'on se connaî j'aime
beaucoup l'ambiance beaucoup de monde
euh beaucoup de familles c'est c'est
très agréable
et voilà donc c'est un plaisir de venir
dessiner idé fixes devant autant de gens
sympathiques une trentaine édition sous
le signe de l'émotion pour l'équipe je
rêvais vu les infrastructures de Buc et
vu le l'envie aussi de de de certains
amis de créer une
petite une petite manifestation du style
de celle que j'ai cité et j'ai donc
écrit à la mairie et deux ou trois
personnes de la mairie ont lu mon
courrier on dit banco en 1993 l'aventure
a été lancée avec une dizaine d'auteurs
au théâtre de Buc l'aventure ne s'est
jamais arrêté aujourd'hui les auteurs
viennent de toute
l'Europe